hello and welcome to another games fall
plays I'm Dan you are John my mr. Aaron
Thompson hey man how you doing I'm doing
good look what we got here God of War 3
remastered just so you talk to HD
collections we're done and dusted yeah
we got another one and you're at the
expert on this one I'm gonna say I know
it's been a while since got a war game
came out so while I frantically try and
kill gods I want you to give me as much
information on this series is verbatim
story from top to bottom kill your way
through all Greek mythology yeah that's
actually haven't made it to the old or
New Testament yet no not yet
yeah they're working on it it's actually
all kicking off right away here we're
just gonna start the show the start of
this game because like the one thing
about this series is that they've always
kicked off with a bang like yeah there's
a big crazy initial level right I mean I
think I'm the higher level one of the
things that god of war did for gaming
was got you out of this mentality that
you'd have to start by killing rats or
killing bunny rabbits right like the
very first god of war you're on the ship
and this giant frickin hydro bursts
through the side and I think most gamers
about crafts themselves at that point
and the thing was like they kind of I
remember at every one of those games
because they started that way
they kind of had to up the ante every
time and started this game it's just
crazy
yeah I mean this series was always about
starting big and then going bigger which
again it's it's you know you don't
remember at that time that actually
wasn't a thing that a lot of games did
right like this stuff look at this as
well like you're right yeah there was
always like a kind of a steady pace
especially the third-person action games
where like you guys you get better and
more skilled and the obviously stuff
gets more difficult but like the pace as
well like it bills to her like a
crescendo almost but these games kind of
rewards like started on a Christian and
then continued the entire like they're
pretty intense yeah and they also were I
mean these games are known to be very
very violent but I thought it was
justified in a way I mean really if
you're stabbing dudes through Greek
history your staff and dudes in Greek
history I mean he's not a nice guy
no criticism antihero and what we're
looking at here is obviously the first
time the god of War's come on the the
PlayStation for their their know like I
love this we're just fighting on Gaia's
like
shoulder the God war series has been HD
remastered before like God of War to
eventually came out on ps3 and this game
came out on ps3 in 2010 I want to say so
it's been a little while since we've
well I guess their husband got a war
game since then but it's been a while
since this games come out and the PSP
version was a change of olympus yeah
that was very good and it's obviously a
big a big you know Santa Monica Studios
owned by Sony and it's a big like big
franchise for them but it is kind of
like it doesn't look it's not looking
like a ps4 game here like this does look
like an HD remaster of a ps3 game
the thing about Kratos his weapons I
remember this series always had a little
bit of trouble with the chains were sort
of the opie weapon yeah like you would
get these other novelty weapons I think
one had a giant fist another had a giant
spear but you know you'd always end up
going back to the chains in this game
because those are the kind of iconic
opie weapons you just grab dues and run
around as well and forget about that
yeah Birla killer oh my god great yeah a
lot of pressing r1 I remember in this
game yeah this game actually has a
history of also what being with Titans I
think in the first game was the one
where there's the castle and the Titans
back into the desert I mean this game
this series just took a button mashing
action game and put you in these
incredible incredible situations there
look at this nonsense yeah like some
sort of tuck what's called a lightning
Titan it's been so long some CNAs games
so hard to remember them all I know my
guy anyway oh my god it's some sort of
horse horse crap yeah yeah kill the
horse crab and the one thing great thing
about these types of bosses saying you
know you're gonna fight this thing about
15 ty yeah over and over again so again
these types of boss battles early in the
game we're always kind of an illusion
usually they don't actually do a lot of
damage to you totally but they scared
the crap out of you just kind of what
they meant to do look at this [ __ ]
you're like you're on top so like you're
on top you're fighting this massive aqua
beast while holding on to a Titan
they're climbing up mantle impass and
you're still getting the like button
prompts
hey you know maybe you're trying got a
couple times well god dammit
yeah forgot how intense these games
actually opened up and I wonder who this
game is for cuz I like it's weird just
having an HD remaster of like three
specifically like having if it was all
three of them gonna be one thing like
obviously sorry this has the DLC as well
we should we should mention so it is a
it is more than just three but like it
is a bit weird and then like I feel like
if you wanted to play through the series
maybe but the fact that it's three like
does anyone did a lot of people skip
three mates so I think it has more to do
with people who myself included started
on PlayStation 2 and played God of War
and then went over to the Xbox 360
because I just felt it was the superior
console for that decade yeah and then
went back to the PlayStation 4 so uh you
know I borrowed people's ps3 to get
through most to go to war and then it
was easy for you to miss this this one
in particular yeah that's true actually
I wonder if that was the case for say
like I wonder if a lot of people and I
know anecdotally some my friends
mentioned that like the Last of Us was a
game that they didn't play because they
had an Xbox 360 exactly when they got a
ps4 was yeah it was like a an easy way
of getting in on that and yeah and when
you get a ps4 finally you know you got
some catch up to do because you were
with Microsoft for a long time yeah a
lot of exclusive titles you just
couldn't get there and we're not talking
a lot about the game player because for
some reason I just assume everyone knows
everything about God Awards they say you
uh mqt easy yeah this this game made all
other games of ute heavy yes holy this
was the one that did it
I think Bayonetta oh is most of its
gameplay to this game yeah for sure what
was that one that came out on xbox 360
it was the one in space it was like oh
my god I forgot it somebody screaming at
it I'll put it in the comments yeah
similar kind of thing like massive crazy
bottles lots of QuickTime events but
like I don't know I always feel like the
God of War franchise did a good job of
having them in important parts and not
doing them for like super dumps yeah I
mean the cutesy easing god of war were
more about messing with you as a player
yeah like seriously you did you know
there were times where you'd be stabbing
somebody and the game would make you do
the stabbing and the person's you know
their face is going like oh no no don't
stab your
my header curb stop me and like you know
the game makes you do it or like some
QuickTime events like for pulling things
heads Park like pulling a l1 and r1 at
the same time I know they also did lots
of ones for of course the wonderful sex
scenes that have permeated this entire
exhibit they took hot coffee and they're
like I think we can double down on hot
coffee
scolding yeah coffee look at that look
this looks really cool
I've actually loved to go back and do we
should do a side-by-side of what this
looks like on a ps3 cuz that stuff that
stuff still looks really cool well I I
feel like just everything else is you
know it looks fine it looks it looks HD
in the way that like when you have a
game that has relatively flat textures
and you just operas them that's how it
looks the way to look at graphics in HD
remakes is they should be up to par
enough that you don't get distracted by
them being yeah but bad you know you can
look at it and and get distracted by it
it's it's more to get that out of the
way sana get these crazy
yeah things out of the way oh I love I
love this one just picking them up as my
favorite thing in this game I hope
there's a bit later where there's like a
lot of them in a row cuz running through
what a bunch of them was always super
fun or like you know the harpies would
be harassing you you finally grab one
just for you like up you don't need your
wings yeah
there you go oh man disembowelling
minotaurs and things like that I think
there's a minutes or near the start of
this as well maybe look at that far
we'll see I don't know how far we'll cuz
that this whole opening sequence really
a lot of stuff happens like in the same
as all of these games did you play much
three when I first originally came in I
know you played the old one you played
two in one a bunch I played up through
Chains of Olympus
I actually was one of those guys that
missed this one because of the Xbox 360
mm change over but yeah I mean as being
speaking of change sorry there you go
yeah but a bit of lore while here like
in between killing off there's not a lot
to recap you pretty much have just
repeatedly killed your way through all
of the gods and Greek mythology I think
by the end of this one most of them are
done the Stephano I feel like I wonder
what then what the future of the god
were series is I mean like I said it's
one of two things either he's gonna have
to start fighting his way through the
new
an Old Testament which I kind of doubt
he'll do more this way yeah well I mean
like what happens when this guy like
kills everybody and becomes a ruler
I mean is he open up like you know evil
Kratos 7-eleven in Walmart and like I
know this it's one thing they never like
talk about in these games is what
happens if they win yeah kinda cuz like
it wasn't like he was trying to save his
family right yeah that was kind of like
a done deal right yeah so yeah I don't
know I guess if it's just vengeance it
was the ultimate vengeance what does he
just like drink himself to death when
he's done with vengeance like what is
pretty violent gambling addict him and
Maya just kind of or maiya
just it's interesting as a mayor because
earlier you were talking about how the
backgrounds in this were like originally
done in Maya right like that
yeah I believe that's what it was the
backgrounds were all done in Maya and
that's why they were like so gorgeous in
3d yeah like they were kind of better
than what the consoles would have been
able to render themselves absolutely
yeah
good a gliding I gotta get your chest I
love how like she's freaking out over
there but I just need my well these
aren't XP any month with my health and
my my Magic's I mean this is one of
those games that also played into the
game violence debate and yeah my
personal belief is that I mean it's it's
in this particular case it's definitely
okay because like the things that this
guy like I almost think it's it's not
good to downplay violence like yeah a
violent thing that is happening it
shouldn't be understated you know yeah I
always find it funny when it came to
these ones because like it's so far
removed from reality you know it's just
like come on yeah like it's it's oh of
course I mean Austin Greek mythology was
not exactly a lot a bunch of smiley
happy people going on there yeah I mean
Greek gods word
thanks you yeah fine pretty moan on
owned by any Greek Church here yes there
what we want we're gonna get struck down
by Zeus yeah that's the world we'll see
what happens maybe actually is not what
happens at the end of this part yeah I
love these guys crawling on their
bellies
I think Zeus was far more likely to
sleep with your wife in the form of
white ox or something like that they
kind of glossed over the
how we sex people with his knocks like
just like a real sexy oxr I don't know I
was going to play this at the start and
I forgot if this game opens with a sexy
nor open it with an epic bottle cause
you can never
oh here we go here we go quick time
events get him my favorite thing about
the quick time just had their like on
the extremity of the screen so even if
you don't know which button it is it's
like oh it's the one down there it's X
it's the one in the bottom I don't
remember if it started that way oh
really
actually I think you're right I think
maybe in the original games it didn't do
that yeah you don't need those valves I
mean all that XP though give it a sweet
XP yeah yeah all right I think we got
one little fight extra fight here we
might we might indulge ourselves with
called to a close
let's see I think there's actually I
think this might be likely to the book
to read here as well goodness this
wouldn't be the first time Kratos dies I
mean he's died a couple times in a
couple different games usually clauses
way back from hell that's part of his
modus operandi this areathis alright
here we go
oh sorry or one keep forgetting yeah
pull that look nothing's easy for it
yeah it's like even pulling that it's
just like a nightmare oh yeah we're we
up let's to be fair gods are super
strong so I seem when they're making
things they don't hang you get all light
touch [ __ ] you video game really Dom it
can be fast Oh like such a jerk come on
run Kratos roll roll
you want to double jump there like that
get their stupid elephant yeah yeah you
stupid God elevator gods just really
seem to like puzzles and this is super
basically look it doesn't even go the
whole way over there you have to jump
and use your stupid wings they just like
really impractical architecture because
I let's be honest they probably don't
even use the front door
well it's like if one of you is like the
water dude and one of you is like the
death dude was like oh we can just
straight up save it or if you want Oh
auto-saves no worries yeah yeah let's
not bother with that
yeah it's like and one of you is like a
Titan in fight the Titans over for
dinner and they can't really fit what's
going on Gaea oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] stupid
water horse situation again oh man
god dammit Eve guy alone water horse guy
looks like we're fighting this again oh
ouch oh no oh no I hooked her in the
mouth
how am i fighting you this is always the
way isn't it trying to figure out what
their what their little move is yeah
he's doing something there anyway
usually it involved them yet putting
their legs down somewhere you don't want
to be oh so it's a three it's a
left-right sweep oh that's a new one but
yeah these initial fights were never
that hard like at the start we're
playing on God's which is the hard
difficulty and but I think hard
difficulty is like second the four that
you unlock the fourth highest difficulty
mu you could get pretty good at combos
in this game at higher levels whoo yeah
I'm not sure how much that stuff's
actually unlocked at this stage because
of course like for those who want to see
all the stuff in the back I gotta hate
this menu so much yeah you've got all
your you know ability slots here burp
then you have all your items here and
then you have learnt
yes that's over here and then you look
your moves here and then back to there
you know it's like a normal menu screen
yeah so obviously like a lot of this
game is unlocking unlocking new
abilities adding in to your arsenal just
filling up that blood Slurpee sounded
basically it everyone like anything died
oh here we go here we go
triangle yeah triangle again just like
I'm gonna seafood dinner deep flowing
this thing there were definitely some
boss fights in got a war over you would
get too tired and you just start failing
the QTE
and then we're tired and fail it again
like stuff to put it down until the next
morning your brain gets tired your
fingers guitar
yeah man you do get a good workout
playing this game alright I think I
might be able to get this one and then
we'll call it a day Oh see I'm getting
see what's happening now is I'm just
like I'm nearly I could feel it yeah I'm
just I'm getting a little bit too cocky
oh you some magic you some magic I'm use
magic in a while oh nice yeah
whirlpool damn alright don't die don't
die down hill that equestrian crab do
you think that sort of crab it's pretty
good question jets no don't you dare
don't you dare kill me oh here we go
don't [ __ ] it up Danny no here we go
when I tell you when I tell you the war
101 ute ute oh oh yeah here we go yeah
with its own crowing the odds that's the
audaciousness there you go get off my
shoulder my friend's shoulder yeah look
at the scale of this stuff it's still so
cool it was a good fight I don't
remember I was 1 or 2 where you actually
fought a Titan and the justification for
you beating it was you were literally so
small it couldn't locate you on its own
body ha ha I was actually pretty cool it
was a good take on it alright I think I
think that might be actually where we
leave it for now there you go that's a
God of War 3 remaster did God of War 3
remaster a master didn't remastered did
it said
from the 14th of this month yeah so if
you want to play some more God of War
triple with some new HD remake graphics
and all that hot DLC and pick it up
that's it there you go
god of war now we need to rest my hands
cuz it was a lot of you put them in a
big old Equestria nice bath yeah I'm
gonna go do that right now
iron Samson thank you so much thank you
as ever and yeah for more games for
please stay tuned to GameSpot calm
you